in the United States people actually own
their own images and it's a form of
intellectual property so typically the
the question of what is my image is a
common sense question but once AI gets
into the picture the question of what is
me what is my image and what is a
transformation of my image that is an
original work becomes very puzzling in
the particular context that we see it
now coming up in the strikes in
Hollywood something even more difficult
is that is at stake so if I own my image
what happens in the world of movies is
that actors will by contract sign away
the property in their image to someone
making a movie now the question is what
do they own
if by AI I can make a whole new movie in
which Tom Cruise is saying new lines and
doing things he never did in the movie
did Tom Cruise sign away his rights when
he signed away the rights to His Image
in that movie or not
AI requires us to begin to rethink
exactly what are the parameters of the
property right and how they have to be
protected by contract and of course the
strike is about what the contractual
terms the standard terms will be in the
industry this is a turning point in law
but how much difference it will make in
the real world no one really can guess
predictions range on the one hand from
the apocalyptic this is The Terminator
when AI develops its own
self-consciousness to it's really just a
toaster that is more complicated than
our old toasters and anything in between
these two extremes
foreign